[Music]
hi hearties I hope you all are saying
safe and healthy during this time and I
just wanted to share a few things that
me and my boys and my family are doing
to stay happy and sane as we stay inside
enjoy a mouse took a stroll through the
deep dark wood a fox saw the mouse and
the mouse looked good response outed his
father dragons breathe fire what will
the neighbors think worried his mother
after that day I became afraid of
heights I was so scared that it kept me
from enjoying some nice scatterbrain
sam-i-am and scatterbrain say most a
cyberbully bike go go gorillas gotta go
high ET Andrea Brooks here from when
calls the heart I hope everybody out
there is staying safe and staying home
during these crazy times
I am currently home in my pajamas and
I'm about to make some peanut butter
cookies and I like peanut butter cookies
because you don't need a ton of
ingredients to make them you basically
only need some sugar eggs um anyway I'm
about to preheat my oven and make this
happen I also hope that you guys are
tuning into one called the heart on
Sunday nights I hope it brings a little
bit of levity to your life right now and
I hope you're using this time to pick up
some new skills try baking and cooking
reading hanging out with friends
virtually not in real life because we
want to make sure that we're practicing
social distancing it's really important
at this time and I
hi et it's Paul green here up in the
mountains it's snowing and just wanted
to take a minute to give you a little
extra love and say hi during this time
and check in on you see how you're doing
what are you up to during this time this
so quiet it's kind of nice no one's
asking you to do anything I've been
playing my guitar singing making fires
baking bread I learned how to bake bread
never done it before
loving that and you know just counting
the days to the next episode of season
seven there's a lot of really big
surprises come and lots of loved and
laughter and romance and adventure all
the things that you love about one calls
a heart so just take it a minute here to
give you some love and we'll see you
soon on the small screen
the medium screen if you're watching on
a big screen we'll see you on the big
screen
take care be well hi et it's Kayla
Wallace here I hope everybody is staying
safe and staying healthy through this
crazy unpredictable time just know that
we are all in this together and I'm
sending my love out to everybody from
here in Canada so some things I've been
doing to keep myself busy I've been at
home I've been playing my good old piano
and writing some music and have also
been cooking I've been trying out
recipes that I've always wanted to try
so that's been a lot of fun so I'm so
excited for you guys to see these next
couple episodes of one calls the heart
these next few were my favorite to film
else
so tune in every Sunday and tweet with
us we love you
hey et Aaron buckles here I hope
everyone's staying safe and staying
positive during this time I know it's
kind of crazy for everyone but we all do
our part and we social distance now I
think it's gonna help tremendously in
the long run and we're all in this
together guys we're all kind of
quarantine ourselves so I think we can
all share in that experience I know I'm
trying to keep myself busy to keep
myself sane so I've been reading some
books watching a lot of movies that are
on my list catching up on TV
we're also usually filming in November
so I never get the opportunity to try
and grow a mustache I don't have much of
one you can tell but I'm trying and
maybe one day I'll be able to grow a
luscious full beard like my co-stars
Crispin Talley and Kevin McGarry the guy
can dream right I'm excited for the rest
of the season
we got the wedding coming up we got some
other great storylines I really think
it's the best season yet so stay tuned
stay safe everyone
I eat either born here for one calls the
heart I hope everyone on your end is
staying safe and healthy and preoccupied
I know for myself I have cleaned almost
every surface so now I'm going to be
making a mess in the kitchen baking and
doing a little bit of cooking as well as
lots of free time I've got a couple
monsters here as well
I am sending all of my love out to you
and I hope while you're hunkering down
first one day that everyone will tune in
to a new episode of Runkles the heart on
Sunday any lots of love to everyone bye
hey et Jack Wagner here I just wanted to
share a few things in terms of what I'm
doing in my life right now to deal with
our situation that we're all dealing
with him actually drenched because I
just finished some cardio and a little
gym I have in my backyard here I also
have I'm blessed to have a really nice
backyard and a really nice house here in
Southern California
we got a little Sun today and you know
what I'm really working on and I kurt
encourage you to work on is that i'm
trying to come from a place deep inside
of myself that is actually not
fear-based but it is actually a place of
calm and a place of love those of you
who watch the Hallmark Channel those of
you who love when calls the heart you
know we work as a community on the
Hallmark Channel the actors that work on
when calls the heart it's a real
community and that's what we feel
especially from our audience and now
this is not just for our audience but
this is just for all of us as a whole
let's look at this as an opportunity a
real opportunity to unite to come
together in this very loving calm place
we all have with inside of ourselves and
from there we'll find our solutions iud
kevin smith here Levon Coulter from when
calls the heart hunkered down in my
house with my wife and kids trying to do
our part and trying to keep the kids
from crawling up the walls we have a
trampoline they're spending an awful lot
of time on the trampoline my wife and I
are doing a lot of cooking I'm doing a
roast right now why shave also doing a
lot of projects around the house built
some shelves today which is something my
wife wanted me to garden but now I gotta
draw the line somewhere I don't guard
that's not my cuppa tea but really all
things being said I just I can't
complain you know with everything that's
going on in the world right now just
trying to stay safe trying to do our
part hope everybody out there does what
they can be good to everyone
treat people well be safe and with any
luck this thing will pass us by and we
can get on with our lives
tt it's Chris McNally saying hi I hope
you're all doing alright I know times
can be tough right now I want to share a
recipe with you it's super simple it's a
cocktail recipe it's a classic margarita
um really easy to make it home all you
need is a lime whoops one line an ounce
of lime juice that is and then simple
syrup which I made at home which is just
equal parts sugar and water and then
normally you would use tequila but I'm
gonna experiment with this mezcal so I
get a little bit more of a smoky kind of
flavor to my margarita and I've got some
salt but you just put on a plate and
just rim your glass like that so I can
do this ounce of lime juice squeeze it
right in here taste that this way second
half of the lime juice normally I'd
measure it out but feeling a little
risky today then we do an ounce of the
simplest here so one in one simple syrup
and lime juice and then two ounces of
tequila or in this case must go and
that's it
while you're listening to the wall album
by Pink Floyd because it's a good one
excellent and then we're just gonna
string in in here like this and I'm
gonna add some fresh ice but you can do
a dirty dump which is when you just let
everything go inside the glass but fresh
ice will last a little bit longer all
over the counter here we go
mezcal margarita Cheers hope everyone's
staying safe
[Music]